позиції на яку я хотів би звернути увагу
поляків нас і весь світ ми маємо
спільного сусіда не тільки Росії ми
маємо спільного сусіда Білорусі і
сьогодні стало відомо що вчора на зборах
силовиків Лукашенко офіційно заявив про
те що він знову відкриває свою країну
для російських військ
багатотисячному контингенту ми вважаємо
що це є одною одним із варіантів
підготовки спроби повторити лютневе
вторгнення для до України з атаками або
за так на Полинь для того щоб перерізати
шляхи забезпечення збройних сил України
ми маємо рішучу відповісти на подібні
загрози для того щоб у
диктатора який намагався проголосити
себе президентом і в думку не було про
те щоб вчинити злочини проти ци
населення України дуже високу ціну
заплатили за ці роки